with our colleagues in the Senate to put
together a really bold relief package
and it's time of crisis now unlike the
financial crisis this is not a result of
fraudulent or irresponsible business
practices this is really a Black Swan
event I will say and we'll do whatever
we need for the American family the
worker and the small business until we
are on the other side of this
legislation the Senate will be an
incredible help there's a few main
things it provides first it provides the
resources for hospitals that are running
low and need the liquidity and need the
help
secondly it provides the family direct
payment for those who have been hurt or
injured in this process provides to the
businesses especially those small
businesses we all know and love that are
shut down now but it provides them the
resources to stay afloat during this
time but more importantly to keep their
employees hired and here we provide the
resources for their rent and their
employees and it will be forgiven if
they keep them hiring and for business
as well we give them incentive to do
just the same as I look at this bill and
when I met on Sunday there's not much
it's changed probably less than 1% but
the number of people that had to make
the decision around their kitchen table
they had a small business to decide to
lay somebody off because the inaction is
wrong that's why I'm hopeful that we can
get this move through the Senate today I
know they have some corrections on some
of the texts I think that could get done
and hopefully will be the time inside
the house I've had been on conference
calls for the last week with our members
keeping them abreast of where we are on
one today and will be on one later today
I want to make sure we review it but do
not slow it down and be able to move
this to the President's desk as soon as
possible with that let me take questions
yes ma'am
well it's not a corporate giveaway let's
walk through what it actually does and
what it provides if you look at the
first portion of it you'll get about 250
billions set aside for direct payments
for those who make seventy five thousand
dollars or less to help them secondly
you're gonna get about three hundred and
fifty billion in small business now
you're talking about more than five
hundred billion when it comes to
businesses who are larger than 500
employees as we hear day in and day out
they're about to lay individuals off
because they do not have revenue coming
in this will provide and much different
than a direct grant or government giving
them money
what government's going to do is going
to secure their ability to have a loan
at a lower rate so they have the
liquidity to keep people working we also
were able to add a provision of a
retention tax credit so in this may be
the employer cannot employ the person
for the full 40 hours government will
allow during these two to three months
to pick up a portion of that by a tax
credit to allow you to keep that person
working it is very important that we
keep individuals in America in a job and
in empecé k-- that will keep us stronger
as we go through and battling this virus
so hopefully we could come back with
almost like a hockey stick approach in
our economy and come back strong this is
so different than the financial crisis
these are not banks because they made
did something wrong these are businesses
that had to shut down for up for
government asking to combat and keep us
healthier and safer and with that will
give them the security of a loan backing
it up going through their banks to
provide them the liquidity but also give
them the incentive to keep people hired
I know we're in a very challenging time
I know we have members who are
quarantine
members who are battling the virus
members in New York City who could not
travel here without 14 days but we I
don't believe we should pass a true true
trillion-dollar package by unanimous
consent there is a way to do it by not
having to have everybody here but also
allowing everybody to have a voice I
think we should have time for debate but
I also think it would be able to pass it
by a voice vote and with a voice vote it
gives you the opportunity that your
constituents and those who represent you
could debate the bill could voice their
opinion and not say that everybody is
agreeing to it yes or no but more
importantly they could also put across
the desk because some have a problem for
travel to get here in time so I think
they could put across the desk where
they would stand on the bill itself I
think that achieves our goal by not
slowing the process down but giving us
time to read the bill and making sure
that it gets to yes sir they have a
bunch over here we'll take so long well
I would hope we had at least have 24
hours the the speaker has said she'd
give us 24 hours and that's why I'm
taking the time right now to our members
walking them through I want I want to
thank the number of the members inside
the house on the Republican side who
worked on this bill early on we did
conference calls with our committees
they worked on our date ideas they
provided it to their counterparts over
in the Senate the way Senator McConnell
after Lee crafted this bill was the way
it should be done he did it
bottom-up where it came through
committees he did it bipartisan where
Democrat senators were involved in the
discussions and he did it bicameral our
ranking members were in communications
with their counterparts over in the
Senate and you'll see a lot of the ideas
through the House Republicans are
actually in this bill the unfortunate
part of all of this is the delay for the
last three days there was no need for
that that was politics that it's worse
the idea that you would have the number
three inside the Democratic Party say to
take advantage of this situation - what
did Clyburn actually say - to recraft a
reform
and the idea of of what they want and
their philosophy that is not right
people are hurting people are losing
their jobs how many people were laid off
in the last three days how many people
had to make that decision when this
could have been passed and stronger for
this American economy I don't have the
complete text yet I have where we were
on Sunday I have the ideas of where
we're going so we're gonna we're reading
through whatever parse we have now I
know the Senators are doing the same I
think that is smart to make sure there's
not a problem with it sometimes when you
move a bill there are always one or two
problems and there we want to make sure
the money will flow correctly we want to
make sure the small businesses would be
able to secure the money quickly at the
same time the hospitals and the states
as well yes well I don't worry about a
campaign right now I worry about the
health of America and that goes to the
individuals making sure they're getting
treated it also goes to the jobs of
which they're losing that's why this
bill needs to move forward I know the
president the action he took early on
denying the flights from China coming
here saved a lot of lives I know he's
taking the advice from a lot of experts
I watched just governor cuomo today say
that the number of being affected in New
York is large but the doubling a few
days ago was in two days than it was
three days and today it's four days so
it is showing that part of this is
working I know the president will take
all that advice and also at the same
time make sure to keep us healthy get at
legislation that gives us liquidity and
capital to keep people employed keep
small businesses able to survive and at
the same time when we get through this
crisis that we could come back
economically just as strong and remember
where we were before this virus hit we
were
our strongest point that we've been in
more than 50 years just the month before
more than 270,000 jobs but right now
it's a different and the one thing I
would say president Trump understands
how to keep us safe but more importantly
also understands how to grow an economy
and I think he'll make sure when we get
through this safely
we'll get this economy back just as
strong as it was before let me clarify
he asked me a question about unanimous
consent I'm not the speaker I don't get
to determine how we vote here so I don't
want that to be true that I said this is
how we're gonna vote you asked me out
unanimous consent I don't think this
could pass on unanimous consent I do
believe a voice vote would allow people
you first have to have a debate at a
time think of the size of the bill that
you're asking members to vote on they
need to have their constituents have the
ability to have their voice be heard
whether they're fort are against it and
why they stand where they do then if you
have a vote a vote a you see does not
give you a vote a you see says it just
passes a voice vote allows you to have a
vote there are people who has a
challenge to get here so it also gives
them an opportunity to put across the
desk where they stand on the bill and
how they would have voted have they been
able to be here I'm not sure we'll have
to take that up as we move forward or
the situation and what's the opportunity
for people to be get to Washington DC
and have time to debate the legislation
did you have a second part of where
those bow
look long-term this country is gonna be
back and we're gonna be stronger and
we'll be back in the house and we'll be
working there's many of us here working
now you watch the Senate what they've
been able to do right now for the
security and health of America people
are home rightfully so but I know we'll
get past this and when I look at what's
happening out there you look at in the
last eight days there are some good more
tests on this virus than there were
eight weeks in South Korea every day we
learned something more about this virus
and every day
through the ingenuity of our companies
we get stronger we find ways it took us
two years before we're in the first
trials when it came to a vaccine for
SARS we are already in a clinical trial
where individuals are receiving the
vaccine it'll take us a year or more to
get there but we're already that far
ahead every day we find something new
and every day we get a little closer to
solving this problem yes sir look I
always believed in transparency I don't
see much change that wasn't what the
Democrats were sticking point was I was
in the sunday meeting they wanted to
change election law they wanted to make
sure the green new deal came in they did
get something in they got another 24
million for the Kennedy Center that's
what we had to wait three days that's
what they fought for unfortunately we
could have passed this three days ago
the president would have already signed
this bill resources would already been
going out making sure people are being
keeping care of their health to these
hospitals that every single member of
Congress has heard from their hospitals
in their districts that they have a
problem with liquidity from their small
businesses is shut down they'd be
receiving the ability to have the money
that to pay their employees so their
employees would not be hearing that they
were being laid off I don't see what
they achieved by waiting three more days
but causing more pain to America yes sir
I used the 24 hours based upon what the
speaker had promised ahead of time that
she would always give 24 hours I don't
schedule the floor that's why I'm trying
to keep our members abreast of what's in
it I've done a number of conference
calls walk them through what we know
about the bill number of our rancors
each day I would think as much with the
bill spending two trillion dollars that
24 hours would at least be appropriate
if not more for the ability for people
to read the bill have the time to review
it not delaying it and then have the
debate on the floor if we have the text
we're sitting on Wednesday yes yes a
problem this is not a moment in time
when all of America is trying to come
together that someone should benefit and
get a higher payment than they're
actually earning why they are working by
taking money from a taxpayer to pay you
I don't think any American would
actually want that so why wouldn't we
just correct that bill so that couldn't
happen it's a text it's a text problem
inside the bill itself the way it's
written it's not hard to correct it I
think all Americans would want that
corrected I don't think anybody in
America would want to get a benefit out
of somebody losing their job somebody
losing their life over the virus let
alone take advantage of a government
during that time yes last question
I always believed in continued
improvement we should do at all times
and if if I look back to the last five
years and you look what Congress has
done we've increased funding for
National Institutes of Health and CDC by
more than 40% we created the infectious
disease task force that actually
rapid-response based upon what happened
with Ebola we constantly improved but
nobody had an idea by how deadly this
was and mainly what I'd say why China
was not forthcoming had China allowed
our scientists our researchers and our
doctors in at the very beginning we
maybe could have contained it just in
China where the rest of the world would
not have the punishment going before
them you look what we were able to do
with Ebola contain it just in Africa
because everybody was able to work
together but yes I think there are many
places we can look and improve and we
should constantly doing that and that is
one thing I know when Congress gets back
they will do but right now the
number-one priority is to make sure they
have the resources and the hospitals to
care for the Americans who get afflicted
with this disease that's why this bill
should have been passed three days ago
that has not changed the funding within
there making sure that small businesses
can still stay employed keep the people
working and don't make them go down
ensure unemployment keeping him in
enlarged businesses that they could stay
afloat for the next two months if we get
through the two to three months and we
can pass this in a healthy way our
economy will be strong just as it was
before so this is a place the government
has a responsibility it's not a place
for someone to take advantage it's not a
place to change election law it's not a
place to change your environmental views
it's a place to focus on the health of
your mother your father your children
your spouse it's a time that all
Americans should come together it's not
a place you should take advantage that
you get more payment in unemployment
than you would
your job itself too many people have
been hurt too many people will suffer is
a time to work together and I know this
is a moment that we all can come
together and I'm willing to work on the
other side just as we did from the two
bills before this and this bill itself
in a way that we can pass the bill at
the same time that maybe not every
member of Congress can come back here
but their voice can still be heard thank
you very much